dafür so hat nix passiert etwas glaubt
netz willkommen beim ein video was geht
ich weiß gar nicht ob jetzt mitbekommen
habt aber ich muss hier 5 wenn also ich
weiß endlich ob ich mitbekommen hat
beides letzte video habe irgendwie nicht
so viele gesehen auf jeden fall habe ich
mir japan zu youtube angeschaut wenn
jetzt noch nicht gesehen habt dann
sollte ich das auf jeden fall machten
wieder noch an und da einfach eine
japanerin die hintereinander 630 donuts
gegessen 36 stück als ich zeige euch
einfach mal einen kurzen ausschnitt
[Musik]
ich meine es ja eigentlich eher dünn
oder ja auf jeden fall habe ich euch im
video gefragt er soll ich das auch
machen wenn ihr bock drauf habe dass man
doch nach oben da und es sind einige
daumen nach oben eingetroffen und
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich komm'
alex ich war eben in einem ziemlich
großen discounter einkaufen und die hat
noch genau 5 packung donuts was mache
ich viel im körper genau alter richtig
kracht oder also wenn ich das jetzt
ansehe denke ich sofort aber ich hätte
wenn ich drei gestern war ich kurz
vielleicht wenn ich noch weiter ein
kluger wir haben hier so klinker also
zucker und denke ich mal ist das oder
keine ahnung was schokolade schokolade
mit streifen schokolade mit schokoladen
ja und ich gucke jetzt einfach mal wie
viele
ein normaler mensch wie ich wieder sage
immer ich bin kein normaler mensch weil
ich youtuber finden egal
mal sehen wie viel ich schaffe ihr könnt
ihr jetzt mal eine kurze pause und
schreibt war bis jetzt in die kommentare
wie viele donuts hab ich versucht
natürlich alle 20 betten aber leute
ich denke waffendeal wenn ich immer zehn
schaffe dann mit diesem video umgehen
okay leute ich habe mir hier so einen
provisorischen ständer gebaut also
vergesslich in die kommentare schreiben
[Musik]
mühlacker
anfangs fand ich eine 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 treffen wir das in der regel schon
ab dem 29
ein weiter ball auf keeper tutorial von
diesen ewigen weil das dort so lange
besteht verkauf sind wieder sehr gefragt
war zwei stück
[Musik]
menschen schlucken hat dann kann er
wieder mehr als ich mache mal kurz pause
donald nummer vier und papa auch beim 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 durch und
dieser pensionist und schlecht liege man
mitte wechseln deutlich durch schaffen
[Musik]
jona 3 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 tore 7
ich bin am ende ist fällig war
[Musik]
wie kann ein mensch 36 monaten
das ist kein mensch mehr dann kommt
diese freunde diese erdbeer teile vor
ihr sie täglich auch nummer acht ich
will nicht mehr und war auch okay leute
und ich habe jetzt schon ab gästen gab
es ein 2 3 4 5 mit 8 19
ihr habt immer viermal so viel und ich
habe ja gesagt henrik schaffen können
ich sagen nein
mit einer ethik als für andere
aufsichtsrats für das am liebsten alle
zerstören wird auftreten wollen
der admin noch nichts block konnte
technisch runterschlucken ich wollte den
runterschicken und nur drei andere
wollten wieder noch mal dass die nochmal
es anscheinend nicht ganz so hart
okay leute einer noch eine menge mit der
waffe in der krippe in einem eck und du
bist weg wechselst du noch heißen mag
[Musik]
meine frau bekommt
wie kann ein mensch 36 tonart essen
ich konnte nicht mehr klar ich mir so
dermaßen schlecht okay ich bin ehrlich
15 habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz
wunderbar schluckt aber ich finde ein
klammer geld lassen
es ist so heftig mit echtem wasser oft
schlecht schon irgendwas aber geradezu
echt übel schlecht ich finde ich habe
jetzt erst finde ich habe jetzt einen
nach oben verdient dann würde ich sagen
macht es mich nach das ist unnötig ich
wollte einfach noch mal testen ob man
wirklich 66 donuts essen kann sowie die
1 3 in diesem video und man kann es ganz
sicher nicht außer man ist keine ahnung
ich weiß nicht wie das geht schreibt mir
die kommentare ob ihr sechstes
restaurants und ein wenig wirklich
können dann machten video zu und schickt
mir aber ich glaube wirklich nicht das
es geht ist es unmöglich das ist ja noch
mal mehr als das dreifache
wir sehen uns sonntag um 14 uhr
ich frage mich auf euch dann kommt
wieder ein cooles video werde ich
bezahlt noch nebel wallen